hello there to our viewers we're in the
Toyota greenroom with CBS News
contributor and psychologist Lisa
d'amour and this morning she's here to
discuss the impact of unsupervised time
on kids and also about videogames
earlier this year Lisa actually wrote a
wildly popular article about video
gaming the particular video game for
tonight and she wrote it for the New
York Times and the title of that article
is called parenting the fortnight attic
Lisa good morning or more thank you
everyone is buzzing about this video
games like everyone's also buzzing about
the World Health Organization calling
video gaming a mental disorder people
are kind of surprised by this and their
guidelines Lisa was that behavior should
be sufficiently severe severe to result
in significant impairment I mean to play
a video games and to be physically that
impaired what do you make about well so
this is sort of an interesting
controversy we have going on in the
field so the World Health Organization
came out and said we're going to call
this an addiction we're gonna say there
is such a thing as internet gaming
disorder the American Psychiatric
Association which is our sort of local
body is not there yet it has been in the
diagnostic manual we use as a
provisional psychiatric disorder but
there hasn't been complete concurrence
around the idea that there's such a
thing as video game addiction so what do
you look for at least when you're taught
if you're worried that your kid might be
yeah what are the signs well so whether
or not everybody's in agreement about
the diagnosis we can't agree that there
can be too much of a good thing mmm you
know and and I think that's true across
the board like it can be true with
alcohol it can be true with all sorts of
things so what we want to measure around
life's indulgences right are they making
our lives better
are they enhancing our lives or are they
crossing a line to where they actually
make things worse so now of course kids
and parents may not be in agreement but
I think we should start from the
position that there's such a thing as
healthy video game use right what would
that look like
because I I feel like there's no safe
sort of housing video game oh you say
there is well let's let's assume there
is let's work with that premise that it
could be for kids a fun way to have some
down time a fun way to relax a fun way
to feel some of the open hours of the
summer
an interesting thing about fortnight and
some other games is that it's actually
collaborative but often kids play
together on teams cuz I be in your home
and playing with somebody in Indiana
yeah absolutely and you're working
together as a collaborative team to try
to make something happen
so there there's you know the
possibility that some video gaming could
be part of a healthy picture of
development okay then the question
becomes like well how much are we
talking right and so the the very kind
of broad lines that we can start to draw
are what kids should be doing a variety
of things yeah you can't just do one
thing all the time even if it's just
reading right we wouldn't actually want
a kid reading for 12 hours a day they
should be outside they should have a
social life they should be at dinner
talking to their family you know they
should be building other skills so the
concern about video gaming becomes when
it starts to crowd out other things
that's when it's an addiction yeah is
there like a time limit you could say
like if you're having more than an hour
of video gaming you're an addict can you
say that we can't say that okay we can't
say that and you know the word addict
you know it's a complicated word so I
think it's really better to think you
know is it getting in the way of the
other things that should be happening
right and one of the ways that parents
can engage this in slightly less hostile
terms right because you're trying to get
along with your kid while also
regulating this is to say it's not so
much that I'm against the video games
it's that I'm for these other things and
before you getting enough sleep I'm for
you being outside I'm for you reading
I'm for you looking over the summer work
that you have doing interesting aspect
that I'd love that you always tell me
that I have such difficulty
understanding is how to have a
conversation with my kid without
isolating them because I have a short
fuse I've come home from work and I just
want to know you get off that video game
enough TV like that's it I'm mom you
know this this isn't a democracy but
you're saying the way you talk to them
there's a certain way that doesn't
isolate your child yeah I mean we can
make it sort of like look I'm on your
side in defense of these healthier
things I think another point that
parents can make easier on themselves is
the moment when you say it's time to get
off and how that moment goes I've seen
parents very successfully say to their
kid if I have to stand over you and ask
more than once or if you don't stop
yourself when you know you've agreed
like you know you've got your hour in
the
if I have to come regulate that then
we're going down to weigh less so
there's got to be consequences gotta be
consequences so it's one thing to say
look we're gonna agree to you can have
an hour a day a couple hours a day
whatever the family agrees to I think as
an additional parent should go ahead and
say when those two hours are up you take
yourself off if I have to come find you
we're going down to 20 minutes you know
or you're going down to zero for a week
okay I think that there's the agreement
and then there's the enforcement of the
agreement and I think often where things
come to grief is when it's the moment of
trying to enforce it so I would build
that into the agreement on the front end
okay I love in your article you talked
about also about fortnight but there's
also a component that for people who
know this video game
I mean it's widely popular for a hundred
million people are on this this game but
it's built to be a little bit addictive
it is built to be addictive and all
video games are right people who are
making video games know exactly what
they're doing and so we have looked you
know on the research side like what's
the science of addiction in terms of
like what pulls kids into video games
who pulls people into video games so
there are things that we know great
graphics and for tonight happens to have
extremely good graphics a game that
advances rapidly things start happening
really really quickly actually pulls
people in a sense of humor actually
draws a funny video games yeah it's got
funny features it's got funny dances
that people do so those are some basics
that we see other things that make games
very sticky is something the technical
term is an intermittent reinforcement
schedule in lay language and everyday
language that is you never know when you
might get lucky so this is how gambling
works right which is you can have a dry
run for a month and then be lucky three
days in a row it makes it very hard to
walk away from the gambling table the
same thing happens in video games and
fortnight has an example of this where
there's a piece of the game that's
sheerluck where you land on the island
what you happen to find and so a kid
could have several unlucky passes at
fortnight and then they have one lucky
thing happen and they cannot walk away
walk away but it is couldn't you say the
same thing to Lisa for are just normal
consumption on social media did somebody
like that Facebook how many people are
watching Facebook
no I've got to go back and check it yes
like it's compulsive to the point that
we can't walk away and it's designed to
feel that kind of can't stop feeling and
even if we go back to the idea of the
intermittent reinforcement schedule
there's something in the notifications
like you never know if you're going to
get one and so that keeps you coming
back to check so if you go a long time
with no notification and then you get a
notification yeah that makes you want to
continue more yeah let's talk for a
minute about the shooting inspectors I
think that's something that parents
really struggle with so for tonight does
involve shooting it involves lots of
elements but that is an important
element of the game as you're actually
trying to kill 99 other competitors of
the hundred who've been dropped on the
island the American pediatric
Association has a blanket recommendation
that kids should not play games that
involve no and it's not a great idea but
what is it that the pediatric society I
think they they feel like it's violent
it's encouraging violence we can't in
good conscience say sure have your kid
play lots of things that encourage
violence yeah yeah when we look at the
social science on this because we've
looked at this a lot I mean this is a
really critical question you know do
violent video games make kids more
violent yeah so the way I've heard this
described by a psychologist named Sean
Greene who specializes in this he said
everyone starts somewhere on a violent
continuum right there are people and he
said wait one way to think about it is
what would they do if they were bumped
into by accident okay would they say oh
excuse me
or would they turn around and punch the
person right like that's sort of a way
to think about where do people start in
terms of sort of their inherent violent
reaction what we know is best as we know
from the research is that where people
if people pay a lot of violent
videogames it kind of moves them on that
continuum got it
so if someone's not violent at all we
don't have a reason to think that
playing violent video games are going to
have much in the way of real-world
consequences yeah
if someone's pretty violent to start
yeah that's probably a reason to say
it's a no-go
yeah so this again doesn't give parents
you know a clear up-and-down about what
they should do but it's helpful context
at least from the research side about
what we know if there were so many
parents are just like absolutely not I'm
never
let my child play video games where
you're shooting at people and then my
husband always says to me his mom never
allowed guns in the house like toy guns
yeah that sort of thing just didn't want
to encourage that for the reasons you
say and he became a war correspondent
you know is there a certain you know you
don't the forbidden to expect of it
there can be that and there's also the
going over to someone's house house I'm
playing yeah right which kids will do so
you know in terms of like real world
parenting how does this play out so I
think there's a couple things parents
can say they can say we don't feel good
about this
so we're limiting it or we're going to
look at the age levels I'm shooting
games so for tonight for instance is
appropriate according to the people who
rate it for kids 13 and up there are
other shooting games that start at
higher age levels okay so I think one
thing parents might say is okay if we're
saying yes to shooting games you can't
play a shooting game for a kid older
than you are I also think parents should
not feel hopeless about it if they know
that their kid is going over to somebody
else's house and playing because as long
as they've said their piece at home they
said look here's why we don't feel good
about these you know and just
articulated their reasons it's not
nothing that their child is sitting at
somebody else's house thinking I'm not
supposed to because my parents don't
feel good about this the values aren't
still being transmitted the filter is
still there it's still there are there
types of video games you feel that are
more addictive than others and things to
look for when you're allowing saying
okay these are okay these are not you
know I think they're all designed to be
addictive I think then the question is
sort of what rings your kids Bell yes I
also think probably the most useful
quality about talking about the
addictive potential of games is that it
helps us appreciate kids are a little
bit at the mercy of this very
sophisticated industry right we worry
about opioids because they are wildly
addictive at the biological level right
that we we sort of appreciate like we're
somebody's up against something bigger
than them yeah it's not unhelpful to
think about video games the same way
that ii a kid is playing a video game
they are being manipulated by an
industry that has designed themselves to
do that so I think that what may not
receive a whole
joyful reception I think it is helpful
to talk with kids about it that way say
look this is designed to suck you in for
eight hours straight that's not gonna
happen here you and I are gonna have to
put some parameters about it that feels
to me a little different than saying do
a kid what are you doing what is wrong
with you you're back at it you know I
mean it's the kids up against something
pretty big so you always I love this and
I said this earlier about having
conversations with your kids instead of
like sort of harping on them and Beall
why are you doing this you are really
great about being open and saying here's
what happens I want to explain to you
why is that so important well I think
then you're speaking to the more mature
and hopefully helpful side of the child
right like and I think all of us and
kids especially we have sort of the
indulgent naughty never want to get out
of bed watch you know binge watch
Netflix all day side and then we have
our rational thoughtful one healthy
things side when we're raising kids and
teenagers talking to the rational
healthy let me help you understand why
we're asking this of you let me help you
understand why we think this is in your
best interest side aligns part of them
with your program against the other part
of them would like to play for a night
for eight hours a day haha I'd love that
you see there is truly a rational side
to teenagers
yes there it really is there and if you
speak to it it shows up I love that and
if you talk down to teenagers they
usually meet you right there mmm that's
powerful that is powerful Wow
Lisa do more we always love it with them
and you join us especially here in the
Toyota greenroom and we want to thank
all of you guys out there for joining us
on Facebook live they'll be much more
thanks for tuning in buh-bye